let's go to the phones and see what is
on people's minds today the phone number
is of course six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty and we will start
today from our caller from the seven
three seven area code caller from seven
thirty seven what's your name where you
calling from that is you that's me yes
it is okay yeah okay so I was about to
ask a question yep
it's on the topic of climate change it
has been estimated that by the year 2050
there will be 200 million climate
refugees in countries such as New
Zealand which I'm from right we have
supported climate refugees when most
people have been in need and I also
understand that Donald Trump has some
very inhumane policies at the border and
in regards to rejecting asylum seekers
that are coming into the United States I
wonder what the rate of job losses that
are estimated to come about due to
automation in the next 20 years
we could see the rise of horrific
demagoguery and potentially a sort of
fascist line and a fascist and a fascist
way of thinking more and more in our
politics yes interesting the way you
phrased in the frame it because the
climate refugee crisis is going to
you're so so ok on the one hand you will
have people like me who have been saying
you need to understand that climate
destabilization is a national security
issue it is a population issue it is a
public health issue because it has these
externalities where eventually people
are going to need to go somewhere else
on the other hand it is going to be you
I mean it's like listen we already know
how the anti-immigrant right is going to
use it they'll say this now justifies
making our immigration law even more
draconian and and and honestly they will
probably convince some people with those
arguments probably yeah
there has to be a massive cultural shift
to take place
yeah yes recent examples like say what
the Australians are doing which I do
recommend you pay attention to with
detaining refugees on Manus anaru become
more and more mainstream I could see
some horrific possibilities become the
case who's to say that a unit he's a
said the US Navy would simply reject an
asylum seeker vessel coming in from say
the Pacific rape from a nation such as
ker bass and Tuvalu and tow that boat
out into unseaworthy waters and leave
and and lead a vessel that is
unseaworthy to simply sink I mean it
doesn't seem to be Donald Trump was
president in 30 years the logical
extension of his attitude today towards
immigrants would be hey folks were
closed the but you just you can't come
in we're closed boats gonna have to go
somewhere else I mean I don't think it
would even be remotely surprising that
that's how he would react to the
scenario your your outline yet for sure
I just see the situation as being so
damned diet it's not other way for me to
put it right okay and very well made
point and we will build that and we will
be in very good shape okay thank you so
much I appreciate the phone call we will
talk to you soon